Welcome to January and our first episode of 2021. By now, some of you are a few days into a new diet, determined to finally lose 10 pounds, or maybe you downloaded a new language learning app and you're planning to resurrect your high school French or Spanish. Perhaps you're working on the household budget so you can find new ways to save money. Whatever your goals are for this year,
欢迎来到1月，也是我们2021年的第一期节目。到了这个时候，你们中的有些人可能已经开始实行新的减肥计划几天了，下定决心最终减掉10磅；或者你下载了一个新的语言学习应用，打算重拾高中时学过的法语或西班牙语。也许你正在制定家庭预算，以便寻找省钱的新方法。无论你今年的目标是什么，
many of us are brimming with good intentions right now, but by February, it's likely that many of us will have reverted to our old ways. days. Why do so few New Year's resolutions stick? And more broadly, why is it so difficult to make lasting behavioral changes? Is it just a lack of willpower or is something else at play? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. If you enjoy speaking of psychology, the conversation doesn't have to stop when the podcast is over.
我们许多人现在都充满了良好的愿望，但到了2月份，我们中的许多人很可能会恢复老样子。为什么新年决心能坚持下来的人那么少？更广泛地说，为什么实现持久的行为改变如此困难？这仅仅是缺乏意志力，还是有其他因素在起作用？欢迎收看《心理学演讲》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。如果你喜欢《心理学演讲》，那么播客结束时，对话并不一定要停止。
Get unlimited access to hundreds of videos about the latest in psychology for just one low price by registering for access to APA's 2020 virtual convention. Start with some of our selected videos featuring psychology's biggest names discussing topics such as racism, stigma, and COVID-19, or use our on-demand library to explore any psychological or behavioral topic. Go to convention.ap.org slash podcast. That's convention. APA.org slash podcast. Our guest today is Dr. Wendy Wood, a professor of psychology and business at the
只需支付一个低廉的价格，注册即可观看美国心理学协会（APA）2020年虚拟大会，从而无限制地观看数百个关于心理学最新进展的视频。你可以从我们精选的一些视频开始，这些视频由心理学界的知名人士主讲，探讨种族主义、污名化和COVID-19等主题，或者使用我们的点播库探索任何心理学或行为学主题。请访问 convention.apa.org 网址下的 podcast。也就是 convention.APA.org 网址下的 podcast。我们今天的嘉宾是南加州大学心理学与商学教授温迪·伍德博士。
University of Southern California. She has spent decades studying how people form habits and how habits drive our behavior. In her recent book, Good Habits, Bad Habits, the Science of Making Positive Changes That Stick. She explains how understanding the science of habits can help us make the lasting changes to our behavior that we want. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Wood. Oh, thank you. It's great to be here, Kim. Your research has found that a full 43% of our behavior is habitual, a number that might surprise some people. How did you arrive at that statistic and what kinds of behaviors count as habits? When I started doing research on habits, I thought, like most people, that habits were just the simple little things we do,
大学。她花了数十年时间研究人们如何形成习惯以及习惯如何驱动我们的行为。在她最近出版的书《好习惯，坏习惯：实现持久积极改变的科学》中。她解释了理解习惯科学如何帮助我们实现我们想要的对行为的持久改变。欢迎来到《心理学演讲》，伍德博士。哦，谢谢。很高兴来到这里，金。你的研究发现，我们足足有43%的行为是习惯性的，这个数字可能会让一些人感到惊讶。你是如何得出这个统计数据的？什么样的行为才算习惯？当我开始研究习惯时，我和大多数人一样，认为习惯只是我们所做的那些简单的小事，
like brushing our teeth or putting on our seatbelt when we get into a car. But we did some research where we actually followed people and beeped them once an hour and had them tell us what they were doing and what they were thinking. And then we later had them tell us how often they do whatever they were doing in that circumstance. And what we found, this is where the 43% comes in, is that. that about 43% of the behaviors that people reported were ones that they were doing almost every day in the same circumstance, and they were doing them without thinking about what they were doing. So there's some non-conscious process there that is guiding our actions because we don't have to
比如刷牙或上车时系安全带。但我们做了一些研究，实际上是跟踪人们，每小时给他们发一次蜂鸣提示，让他们告诉我们他们在做什么以及他们在想什么。然后，我们后来让他们告诉我们他们在那种情况下做他们正在做的事情的频率。我们发现——43%的比例就是这么来的——大约43%的人们报告的行为是他们在几乎每天相同的环境下都在做的事情，而且他们在做这些事情时并没有思考他们在做什么。因此，某种非意识过程在指导我们的行动，因为我们不必
consciously think about them. And that's the definition of habit, is habit that's the definition of habit. are behaviors that you form through repetition, that you repeat relatively automatically, so you don't have to think about them when you do them. 43% is a big number. But, you know, an awful lot of our behavior is pretty repetitive, much more than we realize, because when we repeat things, we're not thinking about it. what we're doing, we're just doing it. And we're typically doing it in the same way that we did before. So that's sort of the way most of us live our lives. And if you had to really think about all
有意识地去思考它们。这就是习惯的定义，习惯就是习惯的定义。习惯是通过重复形成的、你会比较自动地重复的行为，所以你在做它们时不需要思考。43%是一个很大的数字。但是，你知道，我们的很多行为都是相当重复的，比我们意识到的要多得多，因为当我们重复事情时，我们并没有在思考我们在做什么，我们只是在做。而且我们通常在做这件事时采用的方式和以前一样。所以这差不多是我们大多数人生活的方式。如果你真的不得不考虑所有
of these things, it would slow you down, right? I mean, like, you know how to drive a car, that's habitual. It's not as if you have to open the door, get in, turn the key, you know, whatever the movements are. You don't think about them, right? That's what we're talking about. Yep, that's it. If you did have to think about it, it would be exhausting because you'd be constantly having to think about what is the next thing I do now after I've done that. And that kind of decision making is just most of us, none of us, can do it. Our brains are not set up for that. Well, let's talk about New Year's resolutions since it's that time of the year. Many of us have made some resolutions and many of us will, fail to keep them. Now, in your book, you talk about how people think it's just a matter of having enough willpower, but that's not it, right? What are we doing wrong? Well, starting with your first question about how much of our behavior is habitual, habits are a memory system that is very
这些事情，它会拖慢你的速度，对吧？我的意思是，比如，你知道怎么开车，那是习惯性的。并不是说你必须打开车门、坐进去、转动钥匙，你知道，无论是什么动作。你不会去想它们，对吧？这就是我们在谈论的。是的，就是这样。如果你真的必须去想它，那将会让人筋疲力尽，因为你必须不断地思考：做完这个之后，我接下来要做什么？这种决策过程是大多数人、我们所有人根本无法做到的。我们的大脑并不是为此而设的。好吧，既然正值新年之际，我们就来谈谈新年决心吧。我们许多人都许下了一些决心，而且我们许多人也将会半途而废。现在，在你的书中，你谈到人们认为这只是有没有足够的意志力的问题，但事实并非如此，对吧？我们哪里做错了？好吧，从你的第一个问题开始，关于我们有多少行为是习惯性的，习惯是一种记忆系统，它
slow to change. After you repeat a behavior over and over in the same way, say you make, you you may drink coffee in the morning and you probably make it in the same way each morning. And I'm guessing that when you stand in front of your coffee maker in the morning, you're not asking yourself how to do it or what to do. It just happens automatically. You're not even asking yourself if you want coffee this morning. If you're a coffee drinker, that's what you do. So since so much of our behavior is like that, and it has It's part of this habit memory system that learns slowly over time and only changes slowly if you want to alter the behavior. It's very hard to alter our habits once we've formed them.
改变非常缓慢。在你以相同的方式一遍又一重复某个行为之后，比方说你早上喝咖啡，你可能每天早上都用相同的方式制作它。我猜，当你早上站在咖啡机前时，你并没有问自己该怎么做或者该做什么。这一切都是自动发生的。你甚至没有问自己今天早上是否想喝咖啡。如果你是个喝咖啡的人，这就是你会做的事。因此，既然我们的许多行为都是这样的，并且它已经是这个习惯记忆系统的一部分，这个系统随时间缓慢学习，并且如果你想改变行为，也只会缓慢改变。一旦我们养成了习惯，要改变它们是非常困难的。
In fact, many of us think that we should be able to make a decision, right? I am going to lose weight this year. I'm going to make more friends this year. I'm going to be nicer to my family, my partner this year. I'm going to save more money. All of those great New Year's resolutions that you mentioned in the introduction. But the problem is that so many of those behaviors are habits, and that memory sticks. It sticks long after our decisions to change have fallen away and we've given up.
事实上，我们许多人认为我们应该能够做出决定，对吧？我今年要减肥。我今年要交更多朋友。我今年要对我的家人、我的伴侣更好。我今年要存更多钱。你刚才在引言中提到的所有那些棒极了的新年决心。但问题是，许多这样的行为都是习惯，而这种记忆会根深蒂固。在我们改变的决心烟消云散并且我们已经放弃很久之后，这种记忆依然根深蒂固。
So habit memory is great because it gets us that coffee every morning in the way we like it. But it's also a challenge because it is resistant to change. And when we want to change, it's very hard. So are some types of New Year's resolutions more likely to succeed than others? How can we craft resolutions that we're going to be more likely to be able to keep? There's actually some great data on this, and it's not my data. It was done with people who had formed New Year's resolutions, and then were contacted three months later to see which ones they stuck with. And people were asked to rate two things.
所以习惯记忆很棒，因为它能让我们每天早上都按照我们喜欢的方式喝到咖啡。但它也是一个挑战，因为它具有抗拒改变的特性。当我们想要改变时，这非常困难。那么，某些类型的新年决心比其他类型更容易成功吗？我们该如何制定更有可能坚持下去的新年决心呢？这方面其实有一些很棒的数据，而且这些数据不是我的。它是针对那些许下新年决心的人进行的调查，并在三个月后联系他们，看他们坚持了哪些。人们被要求对两件事进行评级。
One is how much fun it would be, to how enjoyable they'd find the resolution. That was one thing they rated. And a second is how life-changing or how important the resolution would be. And, you know, that's why we make resolutions. We make resolutions because they change our lives. So you'd think that people would stick with the ones that were more life-changing and important. But that's not true. Instead, they stuck with the ones that were more fun, more enjoyable.
一个是这会有多大乐趣，即他们会觉得这个决心有多有趣。这是他们评估的一点。第二点是这个决心会有多大改变生活的作用或有多重要。而且，你知道，这就是我们许下决心的原因。我们许下决心是因为它们改变了我们的生活。所以你可能会认为人们会坚持那些更能改变生活、更重要的决心。但事实并非如此。相反，他们坚持的是那些更有趣、更令人愉快的决心。
And part of the reason for that, is because our habits form when we repeat a behavior and get a reward for that. That reward triggers a release of dopamine in our neural systems, and that dopamine works to tie together what we're doing into habit memories so that we start to consolidate and learn to repeat that particular behavior. So figuring out what you can do as a resolution that is to you enjoyable is going to be very important in whether you actually stick with it, probably much more important than most of us realize. How long does it take for something to become a habit?
部分原因在于，当我们重复某个行为并从中获得奖励时，我们的习惯就会形成。这种奖励会触发我们的神经系统释放多巴胺，而这种多巴胺会将我们正在做的事情编织成习惯记忆，从而使我们开始巩固并学会重复这一特定行为。因此，找出作为新年决心、且对你而言有趣的事情，对于你是否能真正坚持下去至关重要，其重要性可能远远超出了我们大多数人的想象。养成一个习惯需要多长时间？
I know there's been some data regarding what sounds like a pretty short period of time for something to become a habit, but I think you have found something that's a little bit surprising in that area. So because habit memories are learning systems, habits are part of a learning system, things that are easier to learn, you pick them up faster than things that are more difficult. So there's not a single number of repetitions that you have to do in order to form a habit. That said, there are data suggesting that a simple health behavior like taking a walk after dinner or eating fruit with your lunch, that those can take, those kinds of simple behaviors can take, oh, maybe two months, three months, to start to become a habit in the sense that they start to feel automatic.
我知道有一些关于养成习惯所需时间的数据，听起来时间相当短，但我认为你在这一领域发现了一些稍微有点令人惊奇的事情。因此，由于习惯记忆是学习系统，习惯是学习系统的一部分，那些更容易学习的东西，你比那些更困难的东西学得更快。因此，形成一个习惯并不存在一个必须完成的固定重复次数。话虽如此，有数据表明，一些简单的健康行为，比如晚饭后散步或午餐时吃水果，这些可能需要……，这些简单的健康行为可能需要，哦，大约两三个月的时间，才能开始变成习惯，即它们开始让人感觉是自动的。
So you don't really have to make a conscious decision and struggle anymore. Instead, there are things that you just do automatically. So give yourself two to three months of repeating things as often as possible, and you should be able to form a habit. Now, some habits that we now have have have taken really years to, to settle in to become habits for, basically for the population, I'm thinking of wearing seatbelts or smoking less or not smoking at all. Can you talk about how they became habitual but why it took as long as it did? Well, smoking has an interesting history because around the middle of
所以你不再真正需要做出有意识的决定并去挣扎了。相反，它们成了你自然而然就会做的事情。因此，给自己两到三个月的时间，尽可能频繁地重复这些事情，你就能养成一个习惯。现在，我们现在拥有的一些习惯，实际上已经花了好几年时间才融入并成为习惯，基本上对于广大民众而言，我想到了系安全带、少抽烟或根本不抽烟。你能谈谈它们是如何变得习惯性的，以及为什么花了这么长时间吗？嗯，吸烟有一段有趣的历史，因为在大约中世纪的时候，
the last century, we started to learn that smoking was really bad for us. And there was was the landmark 1965 Surgeon General's report outlining exactly all of the health risks of smoking. And that had an effect, some effect, on people's behavior. But not a whole lot. I mean, smoking is a habit. It's also addictive. Nicotine is highly addictive. The U.S. government, though, put into place several policies that helped people control those habits. And one was that they banned smoking in public places. So they made it more difficult for people to smoke. So you have to start thinking every time you take out a cigarette.
在上个世纪，我们开始了解到吸烟对我们的健康非常有害。1965年具有里程碑意义的美国外科医生总报告准确概述了吸烟的所有健康风险。这确实产生了影响，对人们的行为产生了一些影响。但并不是很大。我的意思是，吸烟是一种习惯。它也是会让人上瘾的。尼古丁极易成瘾。不过，美国政府出台了几项帮助人们控制这些习惯的政策。其中之一就是在公共场所禁止吸烟。因此，他们增加了人们吸烟的难度。所以每次你掏出一根烟时，你都必须开始思考：
Is this a place where I can smoke? They put taxes on cigarettes, so it was harder to buy them. They took the packets off store shelves so that it was harder to actually purchase them. you have to go ask somebody behind a counter for the particular brand and type that you smoke. All of these things put what we call friction on the behavior and made it more difficult. Made it more difficult, made it more thoughtful. And that cut smoking rates, all of these things together, cut smoking rates from 50%, which is what it was the middle of last century, to about 15% now, only about 15% of American smoke currently, which is wonderful.
这是一个我可以吸烟的地方吗？他们对香烟征税，所以买烟更难了。他们把烟盒从商店货架上拿下来，这样实际购买就变得更加困难了。你必须去问柜台后面的人要你抽的那个特定品牌和类型。所有这些事情都对这种行为施加了我们所说的摩擦力，并使其变得更加困难。使其变得更加困难，使其需要更多思考。所有这些措施结合起来，将吸烟率从上世纪中叶的50%左右降至现在的约15%，目前只有约15%的美国人吸烟，这太棒了。
It's an amazingly positive success story for a health intervention. But it also gives us some insight personally about how to control unwanted habits. I said earlier that your decisions aren't going to last as long as your habit memories. And so making decisions and exerting willpower is a good short-term fix, but is not likely to persist long enough for you to actually change your behavior. What can help, though, is putting friction on that habit, that you want to change. Make it more thoughtful, make it more difficult,
对于一项健康干预措施来说，这是一个非常积极的成功故事。但它也让我们对如何个人控制不想要的习惯有了一些深入的了解。我刚才说过，你的决定不会像你的习惯记忆那样持久。因此，做出决定并发挥意志力是一个很好的短期解决办法，但不太可能持续足够长的时间来真正改变你的行为。不过，有帮助的做法是，对你想要改变的那个习惯施加阻力（摩擦力）。让它需要更多思考，让它变得更困难，
and that gives you some control over it. This is a common idea. There's a saying in marketing that when you go into a store, eye level is buy level, meaning what you can see easily is what you're most likely to buy. They put the cheap things way down by your feet or weigh up high, put the things that they want you to buy at eye level.
这能让你对它有一些控制。这是一个很普遍的想法。市场营销中有一句名言：当你走进一家商店时，视线水平就是购买水平，这意味着你能轻易看到的东西最可能是你想买的东西。他们把便宜的东西放在靠近你脚底的低处或者放得很高，把你想要你买的东西放在视线水平的高度。
That's friction. It works in the marketplace. It works online. So Amazon, for a while, had a monopoly on this one-click purchasing app. Two clicks and you lose customers. One click, you're more successful at selling. things. Friction is really a powerful force on our own behavior, and it's not one that we recognize. It's not one that most of us think of when we say, I'm going to change my behavior. We go inward.
这就是摩擦力。它在实体市场中管用，在网络上也管用。因此，亚马逊曾经一度垄断了这个一键购买应用。点击两下，你就会失去客户。点击一下，你的销售就会更成功。摩擦力确实是我们自身行为的一股强大力量，而且这不是我们所认识到的一股力量。当我们说“我要改变我的行为”时，这不是我们大多数人会想到的力量。我们向内看。
We focus on the things that we're aware of, the things we know, which is willpower and decision. We'd be more successful, though, if we focus on friction in our environment. trying to make the things that we want to do easier, things that we don't want to do harder. So friction has more of a negative connotation. I mean, that's how I would see it. So it's making it more difficult instead of easier. I'm kind of thinking in terms of, I know in your book you wrote about your cousin, right, who periodically announces on Facebook her intention to lose weight, which inevitably fails after a while. And this is something that a lot of us do. We tell our friends and family about our resolutions in an effort to hold ourselves accountable. So does that sort of, what you're expecting is positive reinforcement, will that help people more than friction, which sounds more negative, like taking things away,
我们专注于我们所意识到的事情、我们所知道的事情，也就是意志力和决策。不过，如果我们把重点放在环境中的摩擦力上，我们会取得更大的成功。努力让我们想做的事情变得更容易，让我们不想做的事情变得更难。所以摩擦力带有更多消极的内涵。我的意思是，我就是这么看的。所以它是让事情变得更难，而不是更容易。我一直在想，我知道你在书中写到了你的表姐，对吧？她定期在Facebook上宣布她要减肥的意图，这在一阵子之后不可避免地会失败。这是我们很多人都会做的事情。我们把自己的决心告诉亲朋好友，以此来督促自己承担责任。那么，那种你所期望的积极强化，会比听起来更消极的摩擦力更能帮助人们吗？摩擦力听起来像是拿走东西，
making it harder for you to do something as opposed to easier? The habit that you want to change becomes more difficult. The habit that you want to instill becomes easier, right? Yeah. So friction really has two sides. You're absolutely right in the way you described it. It is a resisting force that you can use to help control behaviors you don't want, but it's also a force that reduces resistance, right? You can reduce that resistance, make it a driving force for behaviors that you do want. Your question about sharing your resolutions with other people, that's helpful. I mean, other people can help us meet our goals, certainly.
让你做某事变得更难，而不是更容易？你想改变的习惯变得更加困难。你想培养的习惯变得更加容易，对吧？是的。所以摩擦力其实有两个方面。你对它的描述完全正确。它是一种你可以用来帮助控制你不想要的习惯的阻力，但它也是一种减少阻力的力量，对吧？你可以减少这种阻力，使其成为你想要的习惯的驱动力。关于你和别人分享你的决心的问题，这很有帮助。我的意思是，其他人当然可以帮助我们实现目标。
And having a great support network is good for our mental health. It's something we should all strive for. But if you're trying to change your own behavior, setting up some sort of public accountability is only minimally successful. The research that has been done on accountability, suggests that it has great short-term effects? The problem is longer-term, it's harder to keep accountability influencing your behavior in the way you wanted to. So accountability is something like our decisions and our willpower that works in the short run, but not so much in the long run.
拥有一个优秀的社交支持网络对我们的心理健康有益。这是我们所有人都应该努力争取的。但如果你正试图改变自己的行为，建立某种公众问责制只有微乎其微的成功率。针对问责制所做的研究表明，它具有很好的短期效果？问题在于从长期来看，很难让问责制继续以你想要的方式影响你的行为。因此，问责制就像我们的决定和意志力一样，在短期内起作用，但在长期内作用不大。
Let me give you an example of how friction can work for us, not. just as a resisting force, but is something that can help us do the things we want to do. It was a great study done with our cell phones, tracking cell phones, and you know that your cell phone is being tracked all the time for all kinds of things. This particular study tracked hundreds of thousands of cell phones to see how far people and their cell phones traveled to a paid fitness center. So how far they traveled to a gym? And what they found is that people who travel about three and a half miles on average
让我举个例子说明摩擦力如何能为我们所用，不仅仅是作为一种阻力，而是作为一种可以帮助我们做我们想做的事情的力量。有一项关于我们手机的出色研究，通过追踪手机，你知道你的手机一直在被追踪以用于各种事情。这项特定的研究追踪了数十万部手机，以了解人们及其手机前往付费健身中心的行程有多远。也就是他们去健身房有多远？他们发现，平均行程约为3.5英里的人，
went to a gym five times a week. But people who traveled over five miles went only once a week on average. So if you're trying to get yourself to exercise more, you probably aren't thinking that much about how far your gym is. You're probably thinking all the reasons why you should exercise, trying to convince yourself, get your willpower to make yourself go. But one of the important factors that influences whether we actually go is how easy or difficult it is.
每周去健身房五次。但行程超过5英里的人平均每周只去一次。因此，如果你想让自己多锻炼，你可能不会花太多心思去想你的健身房有多远。你可能在考虑你应该锻炼的所有原因，试图说服自己，调动你的意志力让自己去。但影响我们是否真正去的一个重要因素是这有多容易或多困难。
Can you find a gym that's close by your work so that, After work, you can easily stop by there. Or close by a store that you usually go to, your grocery store, close by your house. That matters. That reduces the friction, makes it easier to go, and then you're much more likely to actually follow through on your resolution. You've also written about how times of discontinuity are particularly conducive to habit change.
你能找到一个离你工作地点很近的健身房吗？这样下班后你可以顺便去一下。或者离你经常去的商店很近，比如你的杂货店，离你家很近。这很重要。这减少了摩擦，让去健身房变得更容易，然后你也就更有可能真正落实你的决心。你还写过，生活的不连续时期特别有利于习惯的改变。
People are more likely to change their habits when they're in the middle of a life, change, like a move or a breakup that disrupts many of their old routines. Now, because of COVID-19, most of us have been living a good year, about a year in a state of disruption and upended routines. Does that mean that this is a particularly good year for making life changes because we're all in a state of flux and will the changes we're making now be more likely to stick when life returns to normal, whatever that is? Yeah, this is hard to know. We have seen some pretty broadly shared changes in people's lives. Some of them are good, right? So people are eating out less often. So diets have become slightly healthier since the pandemic started. But we're moving less. So there's been less exercise and people have
当人们处于生活变故之中时，比如搬家或分手打破了他们许多旧的常规，他们更有可能改变自己的习惯。现在，由于COVID-19，我们大多数人都已经度过了美好的一年，大约有一年的时间处于生活被扰乱和常规被颠覆的状态。这是否意味着今年是做出生活改变的特别好的一年，因为我们都处于不断变化的状态？而且当我们生活恢复正常时——无论那意味着什么——我们现在做出的改变更有可能是持久的吗？是的，这很难说。我们已经看到人们的生活中出现了一些得到广泛共鸣的变化。其中有些是好的，对吧？所以人们在外面吃饭的频率变低了。因此，自从大流行开始以来，饮食变得稍微健康了一些。但我们的活动减少了。因此，锻炼减少了，人们平均而言
have, on average, tended to gain weight. We've picked up new hobbies, so there's increasing interest in gardening. And people have started cooking, so there are now memes about sourdough starters and all kinds of things. Will people continue doing those things after the pandemic restrictions are over? That's less clear. Because we're all going to get back to our old lives with our old environments and forces in our lives that we had habits for before the pandemic started. And one possibility is that as we launch ourselves back into picking up our lives as they left off a year ago, we're going to start picking up the same habits as well. Because those habit memories are still there. So they're still there to be activated.
体重有所增加。我们培养了新的爱好，因此对园艺的兴趣日益浓厚。人们开始自己做饭，所以现在到处都是关于酸面团酵母各种各样的表情包。大流行限制结束后，人们会继续做这些事情吗？这就不那么确定了。因为我们都将回到我们旧的环境和生活中，回到那些在大流行开始前就对我们产生习惯影响的力量中。一种可能性是，当我们重新开始像一年前那样生活时，我们也将开始重新拾起同样的习惯。因为那些习惯记忆依然存在。所以它们仍然存在并会被激活。
It is an opportunity for us to think about what we want to bring from the pandemic and what we want to change in our old behavior. So it's an opportunity for us to think, well, how do we keep gardening if we enjoy that? How do we keep cooking at home a bit more? How do we keep doing things with our family more maybe than we did before the pandemic? These are opportunities for us to think about behavior change and which ones we want to keep, which ones we don't. But don't be surprised if you find yourself just falling back sort of mindlessly into your old routines because that's your habit memory. It takes actually changing context, as you said, disreaching.
这是一个让我们思考我们想从大流行中带走什么以及我们想改变哪些旧行为的机会。因此，这是一个让我们思考的机会：如果我们喜欢园艺，我们该如何保持它？我们如何能保持在家多做一点饭？我们如何能比大流行之前更多地与家人一起做事情？这些都是让我们思考行为改变以及哪些是我们想要保持的、哪些是我们不想要的机会。但是，如果你发现自己只是不知不觉地又回到了旧的常规中，也不要感到惊讶，因为那是你的习惯记忆。正如你所说，实际上需要改变环境，打破环境。
disrupting the context that activate your habits in order to provide that sort of window of opportunity to make new decisions and to establish new habits. It's interesting to think about it, though, in terms of, you know, so many of us are teleworking right now and our employers have become accustomed to that and realize that we can actually be more productive in some cases. So perhaps we won't be going back to our lives as we knew them before. And maybe some of these habits will stick. So perhaps this is an area for future research for you, Dr. Wood. Exactly. Thank you. One thing I thought was interesting was a study that you published a few years ago on stress and habits. And there's this idea that a lot of us have that when people are under stress, they do unhealthy things like stress eat.
打破那些激活你习惯的环境，才能提供那种产生新决策和建立新习惯的机会之窗。不过，换个角度想很有意思，你知道，我们现在有这么多的远程办公人员，我们的雇主已经习惯了这一点，并意识到在某些情况下我们实际上可以更有生产力。所以也许我们不会回到大流行之前我们所知道的生活。也许其中一些习惯会坚持下来。所以也许这是你未来研究的一个领域，伍德博士。完全正确。谢谢。我发现有一项很有趣的研究是你几年前发表的关于压力和习惯的研究。有这样一种观点，我们很多人都认为，当人们处于压力之下时，他们会做一些不健康的事情，比如暴饮暴食。
But you found out that when people are stressed, they may. actually double down on whatever their habits are, whether they're good or bad, healthy or unhealthy. Can you talk about that a little bit? Most of us think that when we're stressed, we're going to fall back into doing things that make ourselves comfortable. And most of those are bad habits. We will watch too much TV, we'll surf the web, we'll eat too much. But in research that we've done and other people on stress and fatigue, feeling fatigued and overwhelmed, not having much decision-making capacity left, sort of the way you feel drained at the end of a hard day, when you're in those circumstances, you expect to fall back on bad habits because they're comforting.
但你发现，当人们感到压力时，他们可能会加倍执行他们原有的习惯，无论这些习惯是好是坏、健康还是不健康。你能稍微谈谈这个吗？我们大多数人认为，当我们感到压力时，我们会退回到做那些让我们感到舒适的事情中去。而其中大多数都是坏习惯。我们会看太多电视，我们会上网冲浪，我们会吃太多。但在我们和其他人关于压力和疲劳的研究中，感到疲劳和不堪重负，没有剩下多少决策能力，有点像你在辛苦工作一天结束时感到的精疲力竭，当你处于这些情况下时，你预计会退回到坏习惯中，因为它们能带来安慰。
But what we found actually is that people fall back on good habits too. And the reason is this, that when you are stressed or when you're fatigued, you are not as able to control your behavior. Executive control functions are sort of tapped. They are not able to control behavior in quite the same way. And so without our decision-making capacity, we fall back on what we would typically do. And that typical could be something good, right? It could be that you work a whole lot, and that's your habit.
但我们实际发现的是，人们也会退回到好习惯中。原因在于：当你感到压力或疲劳时，你控制自己行为的能力就会下降。执行控制功能在某种程度上被掏空了。它们无法以完全相同的方式控制行为。因此，在没有决策能力的情况下，我们会退回到我们通常会做的事情上。而这种“通常”可能是一件好事，对吧？可能是你拼命工作，这就是你的习惯。
Or it could be that you exercise or go for long walks or call somebody who's a good friend that you can talk with and end up feeling better. All of those things are beneficial habits that you're more likely to repeat when you're stressed and fatigued than when you're not. It makes perfect sense that there would be that pattern if you understand how habits work. But it doesn't always fit our understanding of our own behavior. And part of that is we don't notice the good habits. that we engage in. In fact, most of us think we are acting in ways that are consistent with our intentions, so we must have wanted to do that all along.
或者可能是你锻炼、进行长时间的散步，或者打电话给一个你可以倾诉的好朋友，最后感觉好多了。所有这些都是有益的习惯，在压力和疲劳时，你比平时更有可能重复这些习惯。如果你了解习惯是如何运作的，就会觉得这种模式完全合乎情理。但这并不总是符合我们对自己行为的理解。部分原因在于，我们没有注意到我们所参与的好习惯。事实上，我们大多数人的行为都符合我们的意图，所以我们一定一直都想这么做。
We must work out when we're feeling stressed because we know that that's going to help relieve the stressful experience. Instead of recognizing, oh, that's my habit, and that's why I fell back on it when I was trust. People underestimate their good habits and they tend to focus too much on their bad ones. And that's why we know so much more about bad habits than we do about good ones. What can your work, your science, tell us about some of the issues related to COVID-19, like getting people to wear masks and keep their physical distance? I mean, these are habits that we're trying to instill in people. And we're having a lot of put.
当我们感到压力时，我们会去健身，因为我们知道这有助于缓解压力体验，而不是认识到“哦，这就是我的习惯，这就是为什么我在压力下会退回到这种状态”。人们低估了自己的好习惯，而倾向于过分关注坏习惯。这就是为什么我们对坏习惯的了解远远多于好习惯。你的工作、你的科学研究能告诉我们关于COVID-19相关的一些问题的什么信息，比如让人戴口罩和保持社交距离？我的意思是，这些是我们试图向人们灌输的习惯。而且我们在一些地区遇到了很大的阻力。
in some parts of our country. What can the science of studying habits tell us that would, that policymakers could use to convince people to do the good things? So part of the reason for the pushback, I think, is political as much as anything. And it's based on a misunderstanding of the severity of the virus. But there are absolutely things that policymakers can do to help people stay safer. And we do know at this point that the virus is as much a behavioral science challenge as it is a medical challenge, right? We can control the virus by wearing masks and keeping physical distance from others. We can also control it through vaccines. There's two routes, both are important.
研究习惯的科学能告诉我们什么，从而让政策制定者用来劝说人们去做这些好事呢？我认为，遭到抵制的部分原因很大程度上是政治原因。而且它是基于对病毒严重程度的误解。但政策制定者绝对可以采取措施帮助人们保持更安全。而且我们现在知道，病毒既是一个行为科学挑战，也是一个医学挑战，对吧？我们可以通过戴口罩和与他人保持社交距离来控制病毒。我们也可以通过疫苗来控制它。有两条途径，都很重要。
Estimates are that with the best vaccines, we're still not going to be able to get back to normal until we start bringing the virus levels down in the broader population. At least we're not going to be able to do that very quickly. So using the idea of friction, you want to make it easy for people to wear masks And something that retailers, stores, communities can do is make them free and available when people need them.
据估计，即使有了最好的疫苗，在我们在更广泛的人群中降低病毒水平之前，我们仍然无法恢复正常。至少我们无法很快做到这一点。因此，利用摩擦力的概念，你希望让人们更容易戴上口罩。零售商、商店和社区可以做的一件事就是让口罩免费并在人们需要时提供。
So when you walk into a store, there should be a bunch of masks, disposable masks available that people can use. So they don't have to remember to bring their own. Make it easy for people to keep using masks. Individuals themselves can do things to make it easy. remember to use a mask. Hang it in your car, hang it by your door so that it just becomes part of your habitual every day leaving the house. You pick up your keys, you put on your mask, you leave. Same thing with physical distancing. Help people do it on a regular basis. So the marks that you see in pavements and stores about how far to stay away from other customers,
所以当你走进一家商店时，应该有一堆口罩，即人们可以使用的可抛弃式口罩。这样他们就不必记得带自己的口罩了。让人们更容易持续使用口罩。个人本身也可以做一些事情来更容易地记住使用口罩。把它挂在车里，挂在门边，让它成为你每天离家习惯的一部分。你拿起钥匙，戴上口罩，然后出门。保持社交距离也是如此。帮助人们定期做到这一点。所以你在人行道和商店里看到的关于与其他顾客保持多远距离的标记，
from other people, they're great. They're very helpful. They remind people what to do, and they make it the norm so that we're much more likely to just learn to do this and keep doing it in the future. There are a lot of things that people can do to apply behavioral science knowledge, to help themselves change this behavior,
与其他人的距离，它们很棒。它们非常有用。它们提醒人们该做什么，并使之成为一种规范，这样我们更有可能学会这样做并在未来继续这样做。人们可以做很多事情来应用行为科学知识，来帮助自己改变这种行为，
so that they're able to keep them. themselves and others safe. Last question. Have you applied your research in your own life? Do you make New Year's resolutions and can you keep them? I don't make New Year's resolutions, to be honest. But like everybody else, I try to change my behavior. And given the knowledge that we've all gained in the power,
从而让他们能够保护自己和他人。最后一个问题。你把你的研究应用到你自己的生活了吗？你立过新年决心吗？你能坚持下去吗老实说，我不会立新年决心。但和所有人一样，我试着改变自己的行为。鉴于我们在过去几十年里关于习惯及其运作方式所获得的知识，
couple of decades about habits and how they work, it is possible to apply that in your own life to help with behavior change challenges. So one of my favorite studies was done with eating, and it was done with people sitting in a room with two bowls of food. Some of them had a bowl of apples right in front of them, sliced apples, and then buttered pop. was there in front of them, but they had to reach for it. Other people had the buttered popcorn right in front of them, and the apple slices they had to reach for them. And what the researchers found is that people who had apple slices close by ate a third fewer calories than people who had the popcorn close by. And it's not that they were less hungry or didn't like the popcorn.
将其应用到你自己的生活中来帮助解决行为改变的挑战是可能的。所以，我最喜欢的一项研究是关于饮食的，它是让人们坐在一个放着两碗食物的房间里进行的。其中一些人面前放着一碗苹果，切好的苹果，还有爆米花，黄油爆米花就在他们面前，但他们必须够着去拿。另一些人面前放着黄油爆米花，切好的苹果片他们必须够着去拿。研究人员发现，苹果片近在咫尺的人摄入的卡路里比爆米花近在咫尺的人少三分之一。并不是说他们不那么饿或者不喜欢爆米花。
It's just having to reach for it was enough for. friction so that they were more likely to just eat the apples. So when I go to the grocery store, I typically buy fruits and vegetables that are already prepared or cut up in some way. And they're a little bit more expensive, but I know that I'm more likely to eat them if I do that. So if I'm trying to clean up my diet, if I feel like there's some need to do that, I will fill my refrigerator with fruit and vegetables all ready to eat so that when I open it,
仅仅是必须伸手去能够着它，这就构成了足够的摩擦力，以至于他们更有可能直接吃苹果。所以当我我去杂货店时，我通常买已经准备好或以某种方式切好的水果和蔬菜。它们稍微贵一点，但我知道如果我这样做，我更有可能吃它们。因此，如果我试图调整我的饮食，如果我觉得有这种需要，我会在冰箱里装满准备好食用的水果和蔬菜，这样当我打开冰箱时，
that's what's there. And I make sure that there are things that I like. So I don't buy things that are just because they're good for me. I try to get things that are rewarding and easy. And with those two keys, it makes it much easier to change your behavior. behavior. And we all have to do that. We all have periods where we eat too much, where we don't exercise enough, where we might be a little short with our spouse. Trying to figure out ways to make it easier to do the right thing is a good approach and works better than willpower because it's more long-lasting. Well, this has been some great advice. I really appreciate it. and I'm much more determined now to keep my resolution.
看到的就是这些。而且我确保里面有我喜欢的东西。所以我买东西不只是因为它们对我好。我试着买那些有回报且容易吃到的东西。有了这两个关键点，改变你的行为就会容易得多。我们都必须这样做。我们都有过这样的时期：吃得太多、锻炼不够、对伴侣有点不耐烦。找出让做正确的事变得更容易的方法是一种好方法，而且比意志力更有效，因为它更持久。好吧，这些都是很棒的建议。我真的很感激。而且我现在更有决心坚持我的决心了。
So thank you for joining us today, Dr. Wood. It's been really a pleasure talking to you. No, it's good fun. Thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
所以谢谢你今天加入我们，伍德博士。和你交谈真的是一种荣幸。不，这很有趣。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org 上找到《心理学演讲》以前的节目，或者在你获取播客的任何地方找到它。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见，可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学演讲》由李·韦内曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔丁（Chris Kondyin）。感谢收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。